[Music]
all right i put a new control unit in
here or master switch and now when you
do that not only does it have to be
programmed but the key fob has to be
programmed as you can see
i'm pressing the buttons it's not doing
anything
so we need to program this key to the
vehicle again
and uh
it's pretty simple i'll show you how now
while i'm thinking of it
if this
if your key fob is not programmed to the
car
if i lock the door and open it or unlock
it and open it from inside
and i i'm not using the lock it's gonna
think that i broke into the car and it's
probably gonna set off uh it's gonna set
off the alarm
you know with the horn
and uh you're not gonna be able to shut
it off until you program the key and
then hit the unlock button just so you
know and you can program it even with
the security code going off you can
program a key i've done it before
so anyway all we're gonna do right now
it's in the zero position or off we're
gonna put the key in and we're gonna
turn it to the number two position or
the on position
and we're gonna do that and then i'm
just gonna be pressing you can use
either the unlock or the lock i'm gonna
use the lock button and we're gonna
press that button in a sequence four
times
so we just have to put the key in we're
gonna turn it on wait one second
and then hit unlock
now we wait one second
and turn it off
that's one time
and we turn it back on wait one second
now we hit lock again that's two
then we turn it off wait a second
turn it back on
hit the lock button again
wait a second
and we turn it off
then we turn it back on
then we hit the lock button again
now we can hear them locked that's
number four
we hit it again one more time now it
programmed in now if we had additional
keys we could just hit the button and
program them in but we don't have any
more right now
now we can just turn it off and now
well if i
locked it
see now the keys lock
or it locks and unlocks
i don't know if you can hear that but
now they're working
that's all it takes pretty easy but uh
if you don't do that step then your key
fob is not going to work so in any event
if this video helped you out make sure
to give it a thumbs up thanks for
watching
[Music]
you